joining us with some perspective on
another busy week is Anna Palmer senior
Washington correspondent for Politico
she's also the co-author of politico's
playbook newsletter and a good morning
wait let's let's talk about the op-ed
first which seems to be consuming the
White House at this point thirty
administration officials have felt the
need to come out and say wasn't me how
likely do you think it is first of all
that we actually get down to who it
really was I think it might take some
time but I definitely anticipate that at
the end of the day we are going to
figure out who exactly did write this
op-ed if you look back to the Clinton
administration primary colors that came
out there's a lot of people that are
focused on trying to figure out who
exactly wrote this we hear a claim of a
quiet resistance in the op-ed we've also
heard the president talk about the deep
state that exists there is this just
backing up what he has said before
there's paranoia in this White House
right now and I think this definitely
feeds into that if nothing else this
president is alone there's very few
people that he can trust and this op-ed
the Woodward book just feeds into that
there's very few people that he can look
to to say hey do you have my back
President Obama made it very clear the
gloves have come off now could this like
raise the stakes I think the stakes have
never been higher in a midterm election
the fact that you have a former
president not only campaigning but
calling out directly a current president
is so unprecedented in a very
unprecedented time it's something that
is very important or enough is it good
or bad for the Democrats that it is the
former president who seems to be the
star right now that there isn't somebody
else that they're leaning on in the
Democratic Party I mean that's the big
problem for Democrats who is their 2020
candidate but certainly the former
president of Barack Obama is the
standard bearer for the party he excites
people in the base and a lot of people
have been wondering for the last six
months where are you yeah and what do
you make of his decision to come out now
then I think Democrats see this as this
election as the future of democracy I
mean not not if we see unprecedent I've
said it several times right now but this
is something where I think they are
saying we need you we need somebody to
really tell tell the American people
what the stakes are the Senate
confirmation hearings for the Supreme
Court Brett Kavanaugh just wrapped what
was your takeaway
two things one Democrats didn't have a
knockout punch they certainly were able
to land a few punches but the stars of
these hearings were certainly the future
of the Democratic Party when you talk
about that Kamala Harris from California
Cory Booker from New Jersey really the
standouts for Democrats okay are they
trying to set themselves up essentially
for White House runs down the road is
that what that's about there's a lot of
speculation that this was them kind of
taking their moment and seizing on it
but I would say for a Democratic Party
that needs energy that you have all
these protesters that are there they
were really able to kind of be the new
face and what was their strategy I think
they were trying to find a way to kind
of punch them punch him and find ways to
kind of put some chinks in his armor
certainly they weren't able to find that
you know the The Smoking Gun that was
gonna take his Supreme Court nomination
we heard the news obviously about George
papadopolis there's also a report that
Paul Manafort may be weighing a plate
plea deal what can you tell us well the
one thing for sure
the circus is going to continue around
I've not started this this this case but
you know Paul Manafort has danced with
the idea for the past several weeks of
doing a potential plea deal if that
happens certainly everybody is watching
what he could flip the on this president
what he could say about the kind of some
of his advisors but so far there's no
actual details coming out of what that
ideal might look like all right Anna
Palmer thank you very much thank you